Hey Joe, what's up? Hey, how
are you doing sir? Pretty good.
How are you doing all right. Are you
down to answer a couple of questions?
You want to walk the talk?
Yeah, let's do it. Cool.
What project are you currently working on?
Working on image compression
using neural nets.
Why do you think deep learning
has gotten so popular recently?
Other than it obviously doing
really well in a lot of problems.
I think it also gives people
with a technical skill set
a chance to think about
like big questions, like consciousness
or things like that. Hey Joe,
what's your favorite operating [inaudible]
favorite thing about working at Google?
Um,
I would say all the smart
people and it's pretty flexible.
How would you describe your
experience at Princeton?
A hard and formative. If you could
spend an evening with one famous person,
who would it be? I feel like John Stewart
would be hilarious to hang out with.
Do you play any sports? Uh, I
used to do a lot of rock climbing,
but not so much since I
moved to the bay area.
What time do you go to sleep at night?
What's your favorite car?
My motorcycle Honda to 50
CVR. What machine learning
model would you never use?
That is a trick question. I would
use any model that gets the job done.
Programming language of choice
for machine learning. Tensor flow.
So c plus plus and python. Favorite
professor, Robert Chaperia,
name one person you really admire?
Uh,
I would say any of my friends who moved
to a foreign country without speaking
the language. How are you
liking the bay area? I love it.
Favorite place I've lived by far.
What drives you to do research?
I think it's in that golden sweet spot
for me of hard enough so that I feel like
I'm growing but not so hard that I
cried myself to sleep every night.
Was there ever a class in college
you really didn't like? Um,
I would say, uh, yeah. I'm not sure.
What's the most beautiful thing in the
world? Uh, your smile of course. Ash. Uh,
what's your favorite exercise?
I've been working on the clean and jerk
these days. Favorite food? Who? Dawn.
Definitely. Do you miss the east
coast? Not, not really at all.
What website do you waste time on? I
like the only person I know that doesn't,
I don't really waste that
much time on websites.
I think the last person you emailed,
uh,
I just emailed my team about
setting up a reading group.
You get an all expenses paid trip
to one city. Where do you go?
I really want to go to one of the mega
cities in Brazil. That would be great.
Would you visit Mars? Uh,
yeah, if they have wifi.
What is one thing you can't live without?
I guess I just learned it's Wifi.
What is the first thing you do when
you wake up? Hit the snooze button.
What texts editor do you use? Uh, I wish
I could say something like them or Emacs,
but I uh,
am using a Google internal tool.
What open source library do you really
like? I, again, I'm kind of biased,
but I would probably have
to say tensorflow. What's
one of your favorite movies?
The Matrix.
I don't watch that many movies.
What did something you do to
come up with research ideas?
I love talking to anybody and
everybody that will listen to me. Ah,
that's been pretty good for me. What
inspired you to get into machine learning?
It kinda just happened I think,
uh,
I moved out here and I guess a lot of the
problems that were in machine learning,
some really interesting to me.
What was the first program you ever made?
Probably either hello world or one of
those like four loop things that a certain
number of asterix.
What is one book you really like?
I really like Perdido street station.
What is one thing you are afraid of?
Um, not having a positive impact, I guess.
What is a big misconception about you?
I think I simulate an extrovert pretty
well, but I'm actually pretty introverted.
What is one thing that
excites you? Um, I really,
really love to travel and meet New People.
That's advice you've ever received?
Uh, it wasn't directly like
this, but it was something like,
even if somebody looks like they have
their shit together on the outside,
they probably have a lot of stuff going
on that you don't necessarily see.
What's the bravest thing you've ever done?
Probably moved to California
without having a job.
What is one piece of advice you'd
give yourself 10 years ago? Uh,
take care of yourself better. If you
were a rapper, which rapper would you be?
Probably Snoop Dogg because
of the physical resemblance.
Do you have any pets?
Um, I used to live with a dog,
but sadly I don't anymore.
What's something you've
learned in the past month? Um,
I just learned something about
generative adversarial networks.
What is a topic and machine
learning you like to explore more?
I really like to get into sequence
to sequence modeling a bit more.
Do you think will solve intelligence in
your lifetime? I don't think so actually.
So anytime somebody says it's something
can't be done, they're usually wrong.
But if somebody says that it's going
to take a certain amount of time,
usually it's like 10 x that if you are
in the world, what is one law unit? Uh,
I don't know. NAP time for everybody.
What is something you do to relax?
I read a lot of fiction.
I exercise and a wash Rukh Khan videos.
What is the risk that comes from
deep learning? I would say, uh,
maybe forgetting about all of the kinds
of machine learning that came before
that, uh, aren't necessarily
related to deep learning nowadays.
People want to just throw your own that
stuff and that's not always the right
answer. Who is one person you looked
up to when you were in college? Ooh,
I'm not sure. What were you
like as a kid in grade school?
I think I was kind of a jerk. What deep
learning library do you use the most? Uh,
not, not unbiased here,
but probably tensorflow.
Andrew on one said machine learning is
like the new electricity. Agree. Yeah,
I think that that sounds
pretty good. Uh, it's just,
it's amazing the way people are able
to use machine learning to do a large
number of different things.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is one learning resource you
would use to learn machine learning?
If you're not afraid of doing math
and maybe Kevin Murphy's textbook, uh,
what is it a machine learning, a
probabilistic approach? If not, again,
I'm probably pretty biased,
but I think the tutorials on the
tensorflow website are pretty good.
What is one major unsolved research
problem you'd love to tackle?
I really want to figure out like a
generally better way of sampling the data
during training.
Then uniformly random.
What is the most surprising result
you've ever gotten from your research?
So my team published a paper a while ago
on our image compression work and it's
pretty amazing that we're able to
basically compete with state of the art
without doing anything like entropy
coding or a variable bit rate per patch.
What's more interesting? The brain or
the universe? Definitely the brand.
If you could be an x men character,
who would it be?
A wolverine so I could get the cool like
facial hair. What's your spirit animal?
A squirrel does p equal NP.
I don't have very strong
feelings on the matter.
I'll leave it to the suits
and Washington to decide.
Would you ever go to burning man?
I have gone to burning man
snapchat or Facebook, Facebook,
android or iPhone right now.
Android could go either way or go.
I use Google way more than I use duck,
duck go Linux distro of a two.
All right, Joel, that's
different. My 67 questions.
Thanks so much for answering those.
Absolutely. It's a pleasure. All right.
Have a good one.
See you around.